meu amor acredite em mim eu faço de tudo
para conquistar meu amor por você vai
além de ter o nivel faz qualquer culpa
conquistar você o que é que tu gosta
mesmo é o cod times a o tamar alberto eu
gosto de me libertar eu gosto de dançar
gosta de dançar e tudo isso comigo dessa
música que ó paí ó vista da terra ao sol
e à mesa
só falta a bola rolou a língua e vaga ao
fone saber se o menino não pode esse
tipo de música não caiu tudo procura nem
saber o tipo de música que eu gosto eu
gosto de swingueira eu gosto de música
da banda de música da bahia aí é não
seja por isso eu faço de tudo para
conquistar dj toca à escolha que vai da
bahia pra nós
a própria prisão o canteiro
a prisão de aí galera que assistiu ao
canal todo bom vocês eu estou bem né só
que estou com um pouco de frio que estou
aqui em santa maria é quem santa maria
está muito frio que fazer pra mim tá
frio é o humor do piauí qualquer coisa
pra mim eu abro a geladeira está botando
o edredom em chocolate quente quer meu
deus que fiz no time frio eu não fui um
dos é porque eu só durmo com ventilador
o tal free gelado natasha se não tiver
um ventilador ou não do que acontece com
tajela demais ainda bota ventiladores aí
a gripe a nuvem normal ela vem com tanta
força não entra pelo nariz ela vem pelo
que pagar e rasgando culpa da rampa
assim jovem a gripe pega de um jeito eu
faço aquilo amigo ventilador e aponta o
aparelho pelo menos culto ao barzinho
para ficar legal e avisar a galera do
rio de janeiro que tem chope em
sexta-feira campos dos goytacazes sábado
tem cabo frio e domingo agora dia 15 tem
oi casa grande rio de janeiro capital
a galera do rio de janeiro teve pedindo
no instagram no inep cheque no meu
facebook tempo rio de janeiro não estou
indo para o rio de janeiro agora comprar
seu ingresso no primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo é nóis seja ligado
com ciro sumiu no último vídeo dele e eu
tenho um grande problema com água de
sumir as coisas ultimamente mas quando
tem subido muito andava bem passada
maria vai de táxi e o que acontece e
tocou eu simplesmente estou perdendo
tudo meu tudo eu tenho uma grande
facilidade de fazer as coisas perderão
nada que estava home rodeando essa
câmera pode assumir a qualquer momento é
ser eu acho que às vezes alguém jogou a
praga inserm eu tava vindo pra cá já de
porto alegre pra cá eu perdi a carteira
teria carteira dinheiro documental e
também nunca tem a impressão que eu
tinha uma pessoa rodeada por buraco
negro só que eles então em algum lugar
no topo então se alguma coisa cai no meu
bolso na hora abre um buraco negro de
edson e vai pra casa do [ __ ] era
menor que as coisas quando cai de 6 não
cai no chão na hora que caiu cão
aparelho leva pro inferno eu posso estar
numa sala branca não tem nada nada o
chão é branco é tudo branco não é nada
que eu possa me confundir só tá eu ea
sala solta tiver segurando este alicate
um e eu fizer assim certeza certeza o
calma para tipo assim caiu de mim
simplesmente ela não existe mais
acontece que também eu acho que eu tenho
é uma coisa que pode chamar de síndrome
de crohn incendiou dizer que aquele
mágico dos estados unidos que foi
qualquer coisa aparecer e desaparecer a
gente ficar sem pernas gente ficar sem
graça sob aquela montanha é um mágico eu
acho que de vez em quando essa síndrome
de crise me ataca e ouvir um mágico eu
devo ser um mágico eu não sei porque às
vezes as coisas o me de mim e elas
aparecem outro lugar mas eu estou com
esse pacote dos correios o que está com
um pacote dos correios aqui do nada
somente some
eu tô com ele aqui eu vou beber água
quando o bota aqui ok hum cadê não
existe mais casual sumiu foi embora é
erguer o nada virou pensamento
consciência é ok fico puto chora de
raiva só chora the radio show o tacto
tam catar na minha mão cara na minha mão
aí uma semana depois é só arrumar minhas
coisas em casa onde estava essa merda cá
ray e eu não fico feliz porque achei eu
fui que é tudo é bom fico doida de raiva
porque eu fico me achando imbecil só
pode ser coisa de macho que desaparecer
da minha mãe aparece rolando não abusa
da crise já está na hora que achar fazer
assim encerrou o truque de mais uma
conquista homem muito é o que acontece
muito comigo sempre alguma coisa minha
some e bota a culpa em alguém e eu fico
puto meu amigo fala como se fosse o dono
da razão mas cadê meu celular na cadeia
mas ela também quem sempre votei destrói
cadê meu ser a favor de perdeu assim não
deixando nada no lugar de botas com
quique carro maca mas não pega aqui vai
aguardar aí depois ao detectar fosse o
que perdeu
foi sim eu já procurei em todo lugar não
está em lugar nenhum não tem em cima da
mesa no tac pela janela num café do
computador não está no meu bom tá aqui
mãe já achei dá a desculpa de ama e eu
fico com cara de culpa de desculpa
porque tem coisa que eu desisto já deixa
controle remoto quando perde e ganha
eu procuro assim dois minutos e meio do
controle remoto a de cadeia por pouco
não a cheia de nam
aqui deixa é tá bom aqui o canal do boi
vai assistir o canal do boi nem procuro
não encontrou dinheiro né
eu tenho uma técnica muito boa para eu
pedir dinheiro que quando eu perco
dinheiro fica um pouco de raiva quando
eu acho que eu fico muito feliz e não
importa o valor se eu perder 100 reais
eu xuxa 50 e tal e ganhei na loteria ela
é chave não é nem me preocupo mais o
brother do chaveiro não estou a pedir
tanto a chave da minha vida e eu tenho
certeza que qualquer chave que você tem
na sua casa abre uma porta pode ser a
minha chapa na sua casa é muito chata
espalhados por esse brasil universo tudo
meu som do nada o povo então é barbara
tão rápido que elas estão por aqui a
gente pega o chinelo panela quente mata
barato que levanto chinelo não existe
barato na tela viva o andar que ir lá é
a barata que o incêndio então negócios
ong ness e pede uma coisa está no quinto
lugar em que eu achar essa coisa de três
pulinhos haver gente acha que a gente
acha que não dá aos 3 política tenho
medo de o caso chegar no céu moveu
índios né olhar aqui o w que não é esse
perfume e wilson eu sou eu sou né
wilson ils o mucilon inversão no debate
está aqui pagou tudo na terra aluguel
tac para exportação no notebook aqui a
gol aqui tá pago tá pago aqui tá tudo
certo dívida três por limpa são 11 um
parceiro em parceria ou seria camarote
vip alguma coisa não aqui amigo do no
espaço será que não entra não
infelizmente vai ter que ir pra casa do
[ __ ] coisa que não pode sumir de pé
de mim é meu celular célula assumiu acho
que eu fique no time é uma condição
direto porque a cor do meu celular é a
conexão direta que não sei lá e cinza é
uma cor muito neutra então boa perto
aqui da janela sumiu dentro das roupas
sumiu um fio da história que a
descoberta enquanto todo mundo sumiu não
tô me achando relatou dormir aqui o
botão de barco button foi para casa do
cara época uma parou é o acordo era são
e é isso aí você gostou desse vídeo se
identificou clique em gostei aqui
embaixo até lá no facebook porque esse
vídeo novo é que ela tem
clique em curtir no facebook marca seu
amigo nos comentários o amigo ainda
perdem nas coisas marca seu amigo sonda
subir nas coisas dele marca seu amigo
que você marca seu amigo você emprestou
ao corpo ele subiu foi concedeu é isso
aí valeu tsx vir até aqui vou encerrar
logo se viu que otamendi eu sumir
enquanto assim eu acabava de ser que eu
mude eu sumir enquanto estou gravando